[Music]
so
[Music]
morning everybody it's seven o'clock
here in the uk you are very welcome to
spend your breakfast with us here at sky
news wherever you're watching us around
the world this morning she's said that
reducing the number of migrant crossings
on the channel is her number one
priority and there are reports this
morning that the home secretary pretty
patel is about to deploy controversial
tactics to achieve that we'll talk about
it in more detail in just a moment also
ahead for you
how is the nhs holding off as the prime
minister's tax hike is voted through
parliament figures due out this morning
will give the latest indication of how
badly
more funding is needed we'll have more
on that and
this is
[Music]
yeah you're singing along at home aren't
you the man behind the music will meet
one of the world's greatest songwriters
now rogers that's at half past eight
it's thursday the 9th of september
maritime maneuver reports suggest the
home secretary pretty patel has
sanctioned new tactics to send migrant
boats in the channel back to france
stopping the conveyor belt to crime the
former children's commissioner tries to
prevent vulnerable children falling into
the hands of gangs
cressida's critics says the met police
commissioner is offered a two-year
extension an open letter accuses her of
presiding over a culture of incompetence
and cover-up
remembering the 9 11 victims nearly 20
years on scania speaks to loved ones of
british people killed
in the attacks
this isn't about me it's about trying to
honor the honor of the day
remember the day
[Music]
and looking at the weatherpoint it's
been glorious hasn't he but at the
bright spells with thundery showers
feeling rather muggy today
[Music]
morning everybody the home secretary
priti patel is reportedly considering
controversial tactics to redirect some
migrant boats back across the channel
several newspapers suggest officials are
to be taught how to use pushback methods
to turn larger boats around it comes
after a meeting with her french
counterpart yesterday in which ms patel
said the british public expect to see
results in bringing the number of
crossings down
representing the government this morning
is the care minister helen waitley hello
to you thanks for joining us on good
program i want to talk to you about care
obviously a big topic um this week but
first can i just ask you about those
migrant boats as much as you know
um
are you really going to try and turn
them around well the first thing here to
remember is that migrants traveling on
those boats or other routes like that to
try and get to the uk are of course
desperate but we also know that's a
desperate dangerous way they're taking a
really perilous journey to come to the
uk so we want to deter people from
embarking on that kind of dangerous
journey you also know as they do it then
that puts money into the people's
bundles pockets those organized
international crime gangs so the big
question is what are the ways that we
can do the measures we can take to stop
people getting into votes and coming
trying to get here this way and actually
we have a separate approach to try and
enable safe routes to get here for
asylum seekers so the government has
been looking at in a wide range of
options but particularly to working with
the french and for instance an extra 54
million is due to go to the french so
that they can put in place more border
patrols and use more technology to try
and stop people setting off in the first
place are we going to turn the boats
around well i know that the government
looks at all the options but i think a
really important thing of course is you
wouldn't want to put people in any
greater danger they're taking a
dangerous journey as it is and what we
want to do is actually deter them from
starting that journey in the first place
are we going to turn the boats around i
got i haven't got there's nothing more i
can say to you in that beyond knowing
the government is looking at all the
options do you think it's a good idea
right to do that i said i think one
thing that's really important because
it's again of course isn't it one thing
you can't do that is to think about the
safety actually we
we we want
you know we don't want people to have
any more danger on a journey they're
taking to get clear they need to but
overall turning them around
well i mean
the overall what we want to do is deter
people from taking that route but
actually and we do want to help people
who are fleeing uh for instance you know
the people we're helping coming from
from afghanistan of course 15 000 have
arrived but my question is about russia
of course and i get that and it was a
fantastic job done by the raf as all of
my viewers will know but it's it's
against maritime law to turn boats
around so why is the um home secretary
even suggesting it so what i know is the
government home secretary is as you'd
expect i think looking at all the
options it's desperately difficult yeah
i'm a kentucky including illegal ones i
know that migrants are turning up on the
beaches not very far from my
constituency people see them just
arriving
along the day
so so of course we should look at what
are the options and don't do what's but
i think the really important thing here
is the work that we're doing jointly
with the french and to support the
french to actually stop people leaving
in the first place okay well the french
is saying don't be ridiculous you can't
turn the boats around so we'll wait and
see um
what happens as far as that is concerned
let's move on to the topic that's very
close to your heart um nhs and social
care of course um
looking at the figures and my team
pointed out to me this morning uh the
social care cap will help just five
percent of elderly people receiving care
is that right well what we're doing is
we are embarking on once in a generation
of forms of social care and just you
know give the context and and remind
viewers i'm sure people know this but
governments for decades have talked
about reforming social care and we are
taking this big step well let me just
say so we know all of that you know
we've been talking about it for three or
four days so we're aware of the
background the question is is it only
helping five percent of people that's
not a number that i recognize okay what
i can say is that we are putting in
place that cap which actually will give
everybody
peace of mind of knowing that whether
it's somebody in their family or going
to need care in the near future or in in
the longer term that you might need care
know that the the limit of the amount
that you would need to spend on your
care would be 86 000 pounds that gives
everyone peace of mind and we know that
at the moment one in seven people
receive care um have have a cost of over
a hundred thousand pounds for their care
also as part of this and this helps even
more people we're raising that the means
test the safety net at which you start
getting help so at the moment you don't
don't help until you only have about 23
000 pounds worth of assets we're raising
that to 100 000 pounds so more people
will get help okay i'm not never keen on
talking numbers because it's a bit
complicated in the morning when people
are getting the kids ready for school
etc but given that you brought up the
hundred thousand i'm told that the
government in fact your figures one in
seven people pay more than a hundred
thousand pounds for care so that means
six in seven people don't
so what are you gonna do for them so i
mean firstly to say the six and seven
they are worrying about it because you
never know so i don't know if you have
any family members with with dementia
many people do that i do all of my
family members are dead so no sadly not
i'm sorry kay
um but but
many people do and and the one of the
worries there is the uncertainty you
just don't know how much care they're
going to need and how long it's going to
take and therefore you can't plan for it
so knowing what the maxim is does and
help people plan uh for bills
this is what you could have won i mean
you know six out of seven people do not
qualify for it i was just coming so
firstly i think actually that peace of
mind and i know from my inbox as a
constituency mp as well as care minister
this is something that worries people a
lot the other thing to say is actually
more than half of the funding that we've
just announced for social care through
our big reform is actually to go into
wider reforms of the system so for
instance more funding for local
authorities to help them pay a fair rate
for care at the moment people who are
self-funding paying their own bills are
often subsidizing um the people who have
local authority funded care which is
often at a lower rate we're going to
give more funding to local authorities
so they can pay a fair rate of care
we're also going to be putting over 500
million into workforce training
development to really support our work
and their care workforce is just
fantastic we want them to be more valued
to have more training more career
development opportunities and this will
raise equality okay for everybody too
okay you talked about care workers um
there are i think 120 000 vacancies how
are you going to fill those
well we have been working with the
sector with skills for care which is the
organization which looks at the the
workforce particularly and works with
government on this in the short term we
have for instance been doing marketing
campaigns promoting careers
as a career um but we know that there is
a high turnover in care sector that's
one reason why we're putting this huge
amount of money the 500 million i just
mentioned into a skills and development
program i know from speaking to staff in
job centres one thing they say about
people uh and they talk about social
care jobs is well i don't see where the
career will get me i don't see a career
path so we want to build that kind of
career path with opportunities for
people to gain the skills and really
feel valued in their work as they do it
doesn't help that you're forcing them to
have double jobs if they don't want to
i know this is a really difficult
question i mean the situation here is
you'll know your viewers will know that
care homes have had such a tough time in
this pandemic and that we have very
sadly seen many residents and care homes
die from cobard because they are the
most vulnerable it has to be the right
thing to do to give them the best
because they were sent home from
hospitals when they had coverage um
because they weren't being tested and
this wasn't
this actually and there's been lots of
research done on that and actually this
wasn't the main source of covert getting
into care homes the the reality is um
that you know one of the best ways we
can protect people living in care homes
is through making sure that staff are
vaccinated yes the ongoing testing and
staff are tested weekly is important as
well but vaccinations a really important
part of protecting those who live uh in
care homes and now i've talked to
whether it's residents themselves or the
family members they really want uh the
family members living in care homes to
have the most protection and that's to
be looked after by staff for vaccinating
you acknowledge though that that number
120 000. that's just going to get worse
isn't it i know that the sector faces
eugene's vacancies and that there is a
lot
worse in the short term because those
are quite a lot of people who don't want
to be vaccinated well actually already
90 percent of uh workers and care homes
have been vaccinated there's still time
to get vaccinated and actually i'll say
to anyone i say to anyone watching this
today who hasn't yet been vaccinated no
go and get the jab for care workers
they've got until the 16th of september
to have their first job and then still
that gives time before november the 11th
to have the second job so there's still
time going get vaccinated and then
you're both protecting yourself
and those that you look on what if they
don't
well it has to be the right thing to do
i know that there will be small numbers
who don't i mean there are med if
someone has a medical exemption a
medical reason for not being vaccinated
well that's a different matter of course
but what about the others that don't
what will happen to them on the 11th of
now i mean the big question has to be
well if you don't want to get vaccinated
how can you continue how can how could
it be right to continue to look after
people who are really vulnerable from
covert so they will lose their jobs and
that will make the issue of how many
people are employed and the number of
vacancies in care homes even worse yeah
i mean it will that is the actual fact
yeah but that is why we're working
particularly now we need to acknowledge
that there is yes i acknowledge that in
in in areas where there are some care
homes where the vaccination rates are
lower some good numbers have got
actually 100 all of their staff are
vaccinated but that's not consistent
that's why we're working with local
authorities and local authorities in
turner working uh with care homes where
the rates are lower to really help their
staff have the confidence if they
haven't had the confidence get
vaccinated yet to go and get that job
just to labour this point and then we'll
move on to others there are 120 000 plus
vacancies at the moment that is going to
get worse after the 11th of november
because those who refuse to be double
vaccinated will lose their jobs well
we'll see we constantly see a level of
turnover in uh care homes in the social
care sector actually that's one reason
why we're doing these social care
reforms and as i mentioned that big
investment in the workforce building up
people's skills and the career path to
try and reduce the constant turnover you
see of people coming in and out of jobs
in the care sector we want to make it a
long-term career so that's the long-term
direction of travel what we're also
going to see uh next few weeks is some
people for instance coming off fellow
looking for jobs so there is movement in
the in the jobs market
and and so actually there's a lot going
on to make sure that care homes do have
the staff that they need okay but just
to make the point if on the 11th of
november people who are presently
working in care homes
don't have two vaccinations and a
certificate to prove that they're out of
work
well so the care home and the carer have
to follow their own process we've given
guidance to the care homes about you
know how to um support staff say yes or
no ministry there's nothing or no
question i mean i think it's been it's
quite of course i recognize that there
will be a number of people who really
really don't want to get vaccinated um
and the the caring they're working for
will be able to look and see whether
they can work for instance not in the
front line or not in the care home but i
know that those jobs most jobs in kmart
are on this on the site in the premise
and so for some people we're continuing
to work in a game won't be the right
thing for them but this has to be the
right thing to do to best protect those
really vulnerable people who live in
care homes and at most at risk from
covered how do you feel about nhs
managers earning something like 275 000
pounds a year
yeah it's uh it's an an and
i seen the headline on that today
clearly
i think they're taking a step back
people working in the nhs and those kind
of roles are taking on a lot of
responsibility they're big jobs and
they're moving from having more senior
managers than nhs to fewer through doing
this nhs reckons that it needs to have
that level of pay to have the right
people in those jobs but i do think and
the government keeps a really close eye
on making sure that nhs money is spent
carefully and appropriately because we
want is this much of the funding to go
we want as much of the funding as
possible to go to the front line and for
instance for me
twice what you earn uh it is
significantly more uh than i earn so i
don't want to see nhs managers being
paid at unacceptable levels uh and the
nhs does need to be very careful with
because you almost started by saying it
was unacceptable didn't you well i think
i mean i completely recognized your
reaction the public's reaction saying
goodness look at that big number of
course we do want to have really top
people taking on the responsibility you
know driving forward some of the reforms
that we need in the nhs getting down the
backlog where we just voted through last
night 16 billion extra funding to help
the nhs get through the lack of
responsibility that you've got though in
your job and you know it's almost twice
your salary well well thank you for
pointing out that's true those are what
i do in my job but i mean i think i i i
wouldn't sort of compare them uh
directly like that is a very different
line of work but i mean what i really
care about is making sure that right now
we get all those backlogs down the nhs
all those people waiting for over five
million people
waiting uh for operations for treatment
in the nhs at the moment we voted
through 60 million billion more for the
nhs
last night to get down that back log we
want the nhs to recover from the from
the pandemic clearly they are still
looking after people with covert as well
to get through this and make sure that
we have the nhs always there for people
when they need it beautiful blue jacket
on this morning how do you feel about
being called blue labor
actually i think we made a difficult
decision last night clearly uh and as a
conservative voting for a tax rise it's
not something you do lightly we want
people's money to be in their pockets
people successfully with you tax prices
so of course i don't want us to raise
tax but we had a really difficult choice
here so we had at the moment we've got
over five million people on nhs waiting
lists that projected to potentially get
to 13 million that could be about one in
five people waiting for an operation
that's a terrible position to be in
coupled with me as care minister we know
we desperately need to do social care
reform and governments for decades have
not been able to work out the way to
fund that to move that forward so what
we've got here is a package that means
we can both treat all those people who
need treatment under the nhs and we can
embark on those once in a generation
social care reform it really is a very
beautiful jacket thank you very much
indeed for joining us on the programme
this morning thank you still to come on
the program for you today speaking to dr
schola and scotty about texas new
controversial abortion legislation
that's at half past seven this morning
what direction should the vaccine roll
out go next i'm going to be speaking to
professor sunetra gupta at oxford
university at quarter to eight
and there's nothing you can say to me
[Music]
8 45 big zoo joins us to discuss the
challenges young people are facing post
covet
[Music]
growing numbers of children were being
excluded from school before the pandemic
according to the latest government data
and with schools returning to normal
experts a warning that exclusions are
expected to spike it comes as the former
children's commissioner launches a new
initiative to stop what she calls a
conveyor belt of vulnerable children
leaving school and falling into the
hands of gangs and criminals our home
editor jason farrell reports
english teacher daniel has stepped out
of mainstream education for two years to
teach at haringey's learning partnership
in north london for children who've been
excluded from school they have
no
punishment really did they but he's the
one learning the lesson how to keep
these kids in the system so for example
more of that knowledge will help
mainstream colleagues to um become more
preemptive to spot the signs perhaps of
trauma
to to identify the risks that um that
young people might experience and try
and mitigate those earlier year 10
student miriam was excluded from two
secondary schools for disruptive
behaviour but says mainstream schools
never explored the root causes of her
problems if you're happy to explain
anything like that wrong at home to your
school that makes life easier because
let's say something happens at home you
come in school you're upset and you let
all that anger run upset out then you're
happy to go in to learn you've got a
good mindset everything's fine and
you're ready to get some education in
but if you come in there's no one to
talk to you there's no support you go
into your lesson you're not ready to
learn you're still upset from what's
going on at home
analysis of the most recent department
of education data shows that school
exclusions were on the rise just prior
to the first lockdown up five percent
generally up 20 in primary schools now
whilst there's been a lull due to the
disruption caused to schools by the
pandemic it's fear that that has also
created the conditions for exclusions to
continue to rise the former children's
commissioner is launching a new
commission to look at ways of stopping
children falling into gangs one aspect
keeping them in mainstream education we
know that kovid has dealt a real blow to
a lot of those kids it's meant that the
vulnerabilities they've experienced
often at home you know addiction
domestic violence
have increased and a lot of them also
aren't connecting back into school so
they're at risk of falling off the radar
four percent of excluded young people
are likely to get a pass in gcse english
and maths and when we look into the
longer term we know that even by age 20
young people still not might not have
the literacy and numeracy qualifications
they need to access the labor force
miriam hopes to buck that trend she
responded to being excluded from school
by raising two and a half thousand
pounds to open her pupil referral unit's
first library thank you so much for
coming back today the opening this week
attended by local mp david lammy and
author michael rosen i name this library
the library
her exclusion was mainstream's loss
how often is that the case
jason farrell sky news
uh monkey
what was the boat used to be called is
it boaty but moat face and the library
could maybe be called library i don't
know i don't know where i was going with
that it's only isn't it an open letter
has been sent to morris johnson urging
for the metropolitan police commission
to be replaced critics who signed the
letter have accused dame cresterdick of
presiding over a culture of incompetence
and cover-up it comes after reports
suggested she had been offered a
two-year extension to her contract among
the high-profile signatories were
baroness dorian lawrence mother of
stephen lawrence who was killed in a
racist attack back in 1993
and also lady diana britain whose
husband was falsely accused of child
abuse as part of operation midlands
north korea celebrated its 73rd
anniversary of its foundation with a
military parade the pictures show large
crowds of people in orange hazmat suits
as well as security forces marching in
pyongyang
unlike last year kim jong-un did not
give a speech and there were no
ballistic missiles on display
the taliban says it will allow 200
americans and other civilians to leave
afghanistan on charter flights a u.s
official said a flight is expected to
leave cabal airport today
look forward to brighter skies
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
most places will see a mix of bright
spells and heavy thunder showers today
it won't be as hot as recent days but
will feel rather humid
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
so which was the last british woman to
win a major tennis title unless you
correct me i think i'm right in saying
that it was virginia wade and it was in
1977 as i recall because it was the
queen silver jubilee
okay there you go now it's 20 years wow
says my director amy now it's 20 years
since excuse me al qaeda terrorists
hijacked four commission commercial
planes packed with passengers and flew
them into targeted buildings in new york
and washington for those watching live
on television time seem to stand still
now some very very sketchy details
reaching us here at sky centre important
enough to bring to you though at this
early stage we believe that a plane has
crashed into the world trade center in
new york
20 years ago we'll have full coverage of
the 9 11 attack 20 years on from 5 p.m
on friday i'm going to be in new york
for you heading to the airport after the
programme
that evening friday evening and then all
day on saturday for you from 9 00 a.m in
the morning
among the hosts of names that we will be
uh speaking to is lynn tierney the new
york city fire department's deputy
commissioner at the time of the attacks
who was caught in the collapse and
nearly lost the life
we'll also be speaking to the former
mayor of gander do you remember why
gander was important as far as 9 11 is
concerned all these questions for you
this morning
also to come dr schola and scotty about
texas new controversial abortion
legislation that to come in just a
moment
[Music]
we did the surgery last week in israel
uh the surgery went well we're delighted
to say the girls are doing really well
at this early stage
um i mean all conjoined twin procedures
are complicated but on a spectrum of the
ones we've done one of the lesser
complicated ones with with all these
surgeries there's always the risk of
losing one or both children at the time
of the surgery um
so that risk was there with this set as
well and the other risks of causing
injury to the brain the blood vessels
causing a stroke
um it's it's a high stakes uh high
states undertaking
we're delighted to see they're doing so
well at this stage it's still early days
though you know one does need to wait a
few weeks at least to make sure there
are no infections or any other
complications but you know there's every
reason to be optimistic um
at the moment
well we we believe that there's probably
about a dozen or such
or so kids born globally every year and
whilst we're really fortunate here in
the uk we've managed to gather the
world's largest experience with our team
of five cases now most centers most
countries in the world would not have
dealt with such a such a scenario so the
whole idea is you know whilst it's well
and good that we can do these surgeries
it doesn't really benefit um the
children let's say born in africa or
other parts of the world at this stage
so the whole concept of the charity was
how do we collate all the learning that
we have got in this country and our team
and how do we disseminate and
thereby help the kids
and the families in other parts of the
world that was the focus of the charity
with gemiini untwined
we have a website and please do visit
the website it tells you about the work
we do and how we are at the moment
trying to help other families that are
in this position so we're actively
helping other families in the situation
as we speak
it's estimated that around 70 of our
coastlines are experiencing increased
erosion
[Music]
we start with a steel structure that we
put into the sea floor we then pass a
very small electrical current between
what we call an anode and the cathode
the structure itself is the cathode
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello again you're watching the
breakfast program here on sky news in
the last few moments i've been speaking
to the social care minister helen
waitley she defended the government's
decision to make jobs compulsory for
care home staff with the 11th of
november the cut-off date for those
working in a care setting to have
received both vaccinations
well if you don't want to get vaccinated
how can you continue how can how could
it be right to continue to look after
people who are really vulnerable from
covert so they will lose their jobs and
that will make the issue of how many
people are employed and the number of
vacancies in care homes even worse yeah
i mean it will that is the actual fact
but that is why we're working
particularly now we know
there is yes i acknowledge that in in in
areas where there are some care homes
where the vaccination rates are lower
some good numbers have got actually 100
all of their staff are vaccinated but
that's not consistent that's why we're
working with local authorities and local
authorities in turn are working with
care homes where the rates are lower to
really help their staff have the
confidence if they haven't had the
confidence to get vaccinated yet to go
and get that jab
tomorrow's with us what do you think
tomorrow
well interesting from helen waitley
because the whole of the care sector's
response to this announcement has been
concerned that not enough of the money
will be funneled into social care and
that it doesn't tackle one of the really
big issues which is the fact that the
social care sector is so desperately
lacking in people working there as you
were pointing out to her over a hundred
thousand vacancies and they're saying
that one of the things that makes things
difficult is this requirement for them
to by november have had two vaccinations
most care staff have the vast majority
have but in some areas there will be
care homes where a lot of people haven't
and actually interestingly today the
government have announced their
consulting on whether all nhs staff
that's over a million people should have
had two jabs and if they don't the
implication would be that they lose
their jobs so she says it's very
important to protect people in care
homes that everyone has two vaccines but
certainly it's not going to help with
the recruitment crisis driven by a lot
of factors including brexit and other
things but certainly that's something
that she as care minister will need to
sort out two other brief points 275 000
pounds for a job in the nhs what did you
think about that and also the boats
being turned around to head straight
back to france yes interesting on that
because um i'm hearing that the home
office have actually been working for
some months training border force to
turn
some boats back in order that the french
coast guard would have to get them and
not the british coast guard of course in
international maritime law you have to
safeguard life so there wouldn't be many
cases where an individual boat commander
could decide to do this but that's what
the home office want to do they they we
understand that they've been the border
force have been training for this for
months that pretty patel has authorized
it and believes that in certain
circumstances within the existing law it
could work but probably not many cases
and of course it's incredibly high risk
since the french authorities are not on
board with it um what helen waitley said
about highly paid people in the nhs we
understand they're advertising jobs at
270 000 pounds she said there aren't
many of them they want to reduce a
number of managers and these are
incredibly responsible high-level jobs
but i think this speaks to a wider point
that tory mps are concerned about yes
they voted through the tax rises last
night but i think a lot of them have
doubts that the nhs is being tied to
specific commitments for this money it's
all just come about very quickly and
there hasn't really been a wider
conversation about what the nhs is going
to achieve because you'll remember under
new labour when they gave the nhs
billions of pounds there was concern
that a lot of it ended up going on
salaries rather than expansion of care
okay for now thanks tamara thank you
the us supreme court has refused to
block a texas law banning abortion after
six weeks of pregnancy the country's
most far-reaching curb on abortions in
half a century the texas law signed by
the republican governor greg abbott in
may prohibits abortions once medical
professionals can detect a fetal
heartbeat usually at about six weeks and
before most women even know that they
are pregnant that and other topics now
with uh political and women's rights
activist dr scholler and also our us
political commentator scotty hello to
you both thank you for joining us on the
programme this morning ladies let's
start with that uh abortion rule because
for a lot of women in the uk it's
unfathomable um scotty your thoughts
well my thoughts is it's not that this
is reducing roe versus wade as a lot of
pro-abortion advocates have made it just
simply says once a heartbeat is filled
which is what a lot of majority of those
of faith believe that that's when that
life begins you cannot murder the baby
which is usually around five to six
weeks there are exceptions within that
rule that includes rape that includes
places where the mother's life is in
danger it's like any other pro-life
stance it's just in this case this is
the first governance of the first state
that's actually put this restriction and
like i said it's five to six weeks by
then most women especially if they have
been in an emergency situation like a
rape or a place um they have kept track
of what is going on and realize that
there is something going on with their
body and can receive the proper medical
attention that i think is this has just
been a big a big ordeal uh made because
i think there's a lot of pro-choice
people that are very much afraid that
the roe versus wade is being reversed
and that's not what this law does
okay
so that's categorically unequivocally
wrong
this this um this
is why you call it a harpy bill what's
wrong with that
speaking scotty so this bill is totally
anti-choice it is not pro-life this bill
is just another example of more
fundamental christian extremists trying
to force their views on other people
this bill has zero exceptions which is
why greg abbott said well women don't
worry about it because we're going to
eliminate rape it has no exceptions for
rape and that statement he made about
eliminating rape
by getting rid of every rapist on the
street is so obtuse and speaks to the
rape culture that this republican party
is absolutely promoting so let us be
clear this this bill it does overturn
roe v wade it is now encouraging other
states in the united states to do the
same other republican states to do the
same this bill is purely about
controlling women's bodies this bill is
purely about blaming women and making
them carry the burden that men have it
doesn't recognize that men have a role
to play here
why is there nothing how angry you are
about it it debate it
not from the it's not from the first
thing it's from six weeks the time that
you feel a heartbeat and by then if you
are raped you will know six weeks
whether or not you're pregnant or not
you are paying attention to what is
going on and this is an advocating for
the life of the baby a female baby
is advocating for life get to tell
that's absolutely false what you're
saying
if you wouldn't mind please scotty dr go
on
scotty you don't get to tell other women
that they should know what's going on
with their bodies with my first child i
didn't i was pregnant until i was four
months pregnant that doesn't mean i
wasn't paying attention it just means
our bodies react and behave differently
with pregnancies you don't take that
choice away and six weeks is not six
weeks you should know that you know how
the menstrual
cycle works you know for a fact that for
some women it's regular it's irregular
at some point in time it reduces so no
it is not six weeks women have and
should have total control of their
bodies and should determine as and when
they want to have children if you want
to talk about controlling and stopping
um abortions then why don't you focus on
men why don't we mandate that men have
vasectomies which can be reversed why
don't we
complain
on men let scotty come in please show up
scotty go on
well and this is where i think you see
the both ways i have no problem let's
talk about having male health let's
start having those conversations about
actually been the priorities but here is
where the hypocrisy in the situation is
because at the same time my body my
choice and yet these same people are the
ones that are actually here in america
saying you don't get any sort of care if
you've not been vaccinated you don't
have a body or a choice when it comes to
vaccines but by golly when it comes to
actually killing a life after their
heart is beating that that's all the
woman's choice who gives that baby the
choice and if you are an emergency
situation like a rape i guarantee you
are watching what is going on with your
body you are making sure yeah guarantee
you're not just going to ignore your own
health concerns for sickness
and this is the you can't guarantee
anything of the sword and this is a kind
of this is the issue when women like you
scotty back these kind of indefensible
bills all you're doing is making it
harder for other women to actually
exercise their own free will you don't
get to tell another woman you should
know what's going on with your their
body because their body will tell them
and they will know as and when their
situation arises it should be between
them and their medical practitioner it
is not for you to point fingers at them
it is not for you to say to them well
you should know
ladies um don't talk over each other
because we can't hear what both of you
is saying scotty you go
i think that that is the contrary you
have passions on both sides but the fact
is this did not overturn roe versus wade
plus roe vs wade was not a part of the
constitution it was a supreme court
decision just like how the supreme court
decided because this had gone through
the legislative process correctly that
they could not overturn the legislative
bill in texas so once again this is not
something that was a part of an
amendment this is not a part of a law
this is a supreme court decision and the
supreme court upheld what the texas
legislature did because it went through
the process whether you agree with the
outcome or not it followed the rule of
law okay
uh doctor
final word from this was a republican
agenda from the start and can i just
correct here and tell you again that
this does overturn roe v wade thank you
for the concern for the fetus but once
that fetus is a born child are you
feeding that child are you supporting
that child are you supporting the mother
or el or as we've seen with republicans
you're ready and happy for the mother
and child to stew in poverty and
inequality and injustice all kinds of
things but right now it's all about a
fetus and i'm saying that hypocrisy is
just profound you have to leave women
with their right their fundamental right
to decide for themselves should they
wish to birth a child because they would
be the ones to take care of that child
okay we are out of time ladies but i
must just let you come back on that
point scotty very quickly please well
it's a very selective once again my body
my choice only when it in regards to one
issue not across the board i think
that's where the hypocrisy exists on
this issue once again it's whether you
believe it's a baby when the heart is
beating or if it's just some sort of
fetus like a piece of tissue
okay
ladies very emotive subject for um both
men and women alike thank you for
joining us on the programme this morning
it's always great to see you both thank
you
now on the 11th of september 2001
four commercial planes packed with
passengers were hijacked and flown into
targeted buildings in new york and
washington one of them as you know was
brought down in pennsylvania by the
passengers on board when they retook the
plane from the hijackers as we mark the
20th anniversary this week i've spoken
to the chief uh joseph pfeiffer he was a
fire chief at the time of the new york
fire department he recalled leading the
emergency response in the north tower
all the while hearing people
jumping from the floors above to their
deaths
they landed on
a canopy over the front of the
the the
entrance to the lobby
with a loud thud
and we knew that each thud
was the end of a life
more than 200 people
jumped to their deaths from those twin
towers before they
collapsed the cause of death uh recorded
as a blunt
trauma as a result of homicide
and we'll have full coverage of the 9 11
attack 20 years on from 5 o'clock on
friday i'll be in new york that evening
and again on saturday morning the day of
the anniversary from 9am and
throughout the day i'd be honored if you
could join me
at one of those hours or indeed if you'd
like to stay with us throughout the
course of the day as we hear the names
read out of those that perished almost 3
000 people
lost their lives among a host of others
i'll be speaking to george pataki he was
the new york governor at the time about
his experience
leading the state through the crisis
and as i said about 20 minutes ago i'll
also be talking to the mayor of gander
gander was the place in canada where so
many of the aeroplanes that couldn't go
into u.s airspace it was closed for two
days remember at the time didn't open
again until the 13th of september that's
where all the planes landed it was a
tiny town of just 5 000 people opened
their doors to many many thousands more
until the airspace was reopened uh
speaking to the mayor of gander at the
time um over the weekend stay tuned for
more on that this hour though what next
with a vaccine rollout it's a question
dividing the scientific community we'll
speak to professor sunetra gupta next
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
i witnessed how the catalan fight for
independence split families it was from
this chamber that carlos putimon
declared independence in october
i come here because i want to show other
people what happened
i'm michelle clifford and i'm sky's
europe correspondent
it's not the aim of the smugglers to
actually get people to uk shores but
simply into british waters
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are real concerns here now about
whether the health system will be able
to cope
[Music]
president macron has spoken in defense
of freedom of expression saying france
won't give up its caricatures and
drawings
made by people who dare to challenge
afternoon mr barnier how are you
i have no time for any politics
[Music]
anger about wider social and economic
problems in this nation
we are on the verge of fascism and we
have a country
[Music]
it was my vision to come and protect
regulation future
[Music]
animals like lion can enter into bomas
they kill their livestocks and this
leads to human wildlife country
[Music]
did you know that if we make small
changes to our lives we can reduce air
pollution by loads but how much exactly
loads
overnight fog will clear to brighter
spells but showers will break out widely
today some of the showers will be heavy
in thunder and could lead to localized
flooding not as hot as yesterday but
still feeling rather humid the far north
and northwest of scotland cloudy with
spells of rain
taking a look at the daily air quality
index where levels of air pollution are
banded from one being low to 10 being
very high
levels will be mostly low with isolated
pockets of moderate air pollution as
unsettled weather sweeps northwards
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
governments announced a consultation
into whether they should make the
coronavirus vaccine mandatory for all
frontline health and care staff it's a
question stepped in controversy with
fears of a looming staffing crisis the
thousands of currently unvaccinated nhs
workers are banned from working let's
talk about it in more detail
in fact let's talk about it generally as
far as um the epidemiology of it is
concerned and dr sunetra gupta is with
us professor of theoretical epidemiology
at the university of oxford thank you
for joining us on the programme this
morning um
let's talk about the the
vaccines and the boosters and comparing
it um and contrasting it with the
vaccine for flu etc all these things are
what people are having to contend with
at the moment break it down for us what
should we be thinking about
well first of all we should be thinking
about what the vaccine actually delivers
and what we've done continuously
throughout the course of this pandemic
is take some of the wonderful tools that
we have and push them to do what they
can't do
so we have for example mathematical
models which are fantastic conceptual
tools and they've been pushed beyond
their capacity
to do what they can't do which is to
predict how many cases they'll be and
how many deaths they'll be
we have vaccines which are meant to
protect against disease and death
amongst those who are vulnerable to
those conditions and instead we've been
pushing them to do what they can't do
which is protect against transmission
once you take on board the fact that
vaccines are supposed to protect
against severe disease and death and
this was recognized by many people at
the outset including kate bingham who
said you know we'll vaccinate everyone
over 50 and then that's it we've done
our job and the vaccines have done their
job they've been superlative in doing
their job uh so far we're protecting
people against severe disease and death
they were never meant to be used to stop
transmission or so to
allow people in particular settings
to make them risk free
so it is really not logical to use
vaccines to protect other people the
vaccine protects you
um which if you're vulnerable is really
a very very valuable
thing what we really should be thinking
okay so professor
i get that so
from what you're saying can i
extrapolate from that that you don't
think that nhs and care workers need to
have vaccines unless they want to you
don't think they should be forced to
i don't think they should be forced to
on
the understanding but
simply because this vaccine does not
prevent transmission so if you just
think of the logic of it
what is the point of requiring a vaccine
to protect others if that vaccine does
not
durably prevent onward transmission
of a virus
so i mean obviously there are all sorts
of ethical and political issues
surrounding this but we can peel it
right back to the logic and the logic
is simply not there it's illogical to
foster vaccine upon people
in the hope that you can reduce
the transmission of disease and we've
seen that it's been borne out for
example in israel where cases are rising
despite vaccination the good news is
that provided you've protected those who
are vulnerable to disease and death we
don't need to worry
so we are unnecessarily inflicting upon
ourselves this worry
that
we will be transmitting the virus to
someone who's going to die okay
professor let me ask you about in that
case let me move on to boosters
um so if somebody has been double
vaccinated they are protected more or
less
but will those elderly people in care
homes need to have booster jobs and will
the rest of us
well that's a very good question um you
know again if you think about
are we
provided we
focus on those who are vulnerable
um it's a very good question about
whether boosters may in fact enhance or
maintain a longer-term protection
against severe disease and death and at
the moment the decision to try and boost
immunity amongst those who um you know
are of obviously not
mounting a strong immune response to the
vaccine seems to me to be a logical risk
to take so there will be some
small risk at least attached to further
vaccination but what we need of course
are studies
to see whether that small risk is
outweighed
by the advantage which may be that it
makes protection against severe disease
and death more durable
and final thought before i let you go
doc absolutely fascinating stuff
professor should 12 year olds be
vaccinated
i absolutely do not think that is
logical at any level i mean leave alone
the ethics of
using 12 year olds as barriers for
infection
for the community the fundamental the
bottom line is that these vaccines do
not prevent transmission
so these vaccines do not benefit in the
case of a 12 year old it benefits
neither the individual who is not at
risk of severe disease and death
nor does it benefit the community so all
we're left with is a risk of vaccination
to ask children to bear that risk to me
is just simply uh unacceptable and
further than that we had the health
secretary on the program uh yesterday
morning and he was saying that 12 year
olds should be able to override their
anti-vaxx parents if they wanted to have
the jab quick thought on that before i
let you go
well i find that very very difficult um
to understand mostly we don't leave such
decisions to twelve-year-olds
and um you know we're not
if we were in a situation where there
was a huge medical emergency 12 year
olds were dying in droves and we had to
roll this out
we might
consider such an extraordinary measure
but in under these circumstances where
the vaccine is being offered to 12 year
olds to protect the community um you
know given that most people are
struggling with that concept the idea
that a 12 year old would immediately be
able to make a rational decision
um
given all the facts it is really kind of
difficult to understand
i'm so sorry we are out of time but
absolutely fascinating thanks for
clearing up some of those subjects for
us here on sky news this morning thank
you very quick look at the weather for
you